PROFESSOR: I'll begin
by reviewing quickly
what we did last time.
We considered what are called
finite range potentials,
in which over a distance
R, in the x-axis,
there's a non-zero potential.
So the potential is some v of x
for x between capital R and 0,
is equal to 0 for x
larger than capital R,
and it's infinity
for x negative.
So there's a wall at x equals 0.
And there can be some
potential, but this
is called a finite range
potential, because nothing
happens after distance R.
As usual, we considered
scattering solutions, solutions
that are unnormalizable
with energies,
h squared k squared over 2m,
for a particle with mass m.
And if we had no potential,
we wrote the solution phi
of x, the wave function,
which was sine of kx.
And we also wrote it
as a superposition
of an incoming wave.
Now, an incoming
wave in this set up
is a wave that propagates
from plus infinity towards 0.
And a reflected wave is
a wave that bounces back
and propagates towards
more positive x.
So here we'll
write this as minus
e to the minus ikx over 2i,
plus e to the ikx over 2i.
This is the sine
function rewritten
in terms of exponential
in such a way that
here is the incoming wave.
Remember the time dependence
is minus iet over h bar.
So this wave
combined with a time
is a wave that is moving
towards the origin.
This wave is moving outwards.
Then we said that there would
be, in general, with potential.
With a potential, you would
have a solution psi effects,
which we wrote after some
tinkering in the farm
i delta sine of kx plus delta.
And if you look at the
part of the phase that
has the minus ikx would have a
minus delta and a delta here.
So they would cancel.
So this solution has
the same incoming wave
as the no potential solution.
On the other hand here, you
would have e to the 2i delta,
e to the ikx over
2i, and this solution
is only valid for x
greater than R. You see,
this is just a plane
wave after all.
There's nothing more than a
plane wave and a phase shift.
The phase shift,
of course, doesn't
make the solution any more
complicated or subtle,
but what it does is, by
depending on the energy,
this phase shift delta depends
on the energy, and we're on k.
Then, it produces
interesting phenomena
when you send in wave packets.
So if we write psi,
we usually write
psi is equal to
the phi plus psi s,
where psi s is called
the scattered wave.
You see, the full wave that
you get, for x greater than R,
we would have to solve and work
very carefully to figure out
what is the wave function
in the region 0 to R.
But for x greater
than R is simple,
and for x greater than
R the wave function psi
is the free wave function,
in the case of no potential,
plus the scattered wave.
Quick calculation with this,
things [? give to ?] you
the scatter wave is e to the i
delta sine delta e to the ikx
is an outgoing wave.
And this coefficient is called
the scattering amplitude.
It's the amplitude of
the scattered wave.
This is a wave that is going
out, and this is its amplitude.
So it has something to do with
the strength of the scattering,
because if there
was no scattering,
the wave function would
just behave like the no
potential wave function.
But due to the potential,
there is an extra piece,
and that represents
an outgoing wave
beyond what you get outgoing
with a free no potential wave
function.
So it's the
scattering amplitude,
and therefore sometimes we
are interested in as squared,
which is just sine
squared delta.
Anyway, those are the
things we did last time.
And we can connect to some
ideas that we were talking about
in the past, having to
do with time delays,
by constructing a wave packet.
That's what's usually done.
Consider the process
of time delay, which
is a phenomenon
that we've observed
happens in several
circumstances.
If you have an incident
wave, how do you
construct an incident wave?
Well, it has to be
a superposition of e
to the minus ikx, for sure.
So we'll put the function in
front, we'll integrate over k,
and we'll go from 0 to infinity.
I will actually add the
time dependence as well.
So let's do phi of x and t.
Then, we would have e to the
minus i, e of k, t over h bar,
and this would be valid
for x greater than R.
Again, as a solution of
the Schrodinger equation.
You see, it's a free wave.
There's nothing extra from what
you know from the de Broglie
waves we started
a long time ago.
So if this is your
incident wave,
you have to now realize that
you have this equation over here
telling you about the general
solution of the Schrodinger
equation.
The general solution of
the Schrodinger equation,
in this simple region,
the outside region,
is of this form, and it
depends on this delta
that must be calculated.
This is the incoming wave,
this is the reflected wave,
and this is a solution.
So by superposition, I construct
the reflected wave of x and t.
So for each e to
the minus ikx wave,
I must put down
one e to the ikx,
but I must also put an e to
the 2i delta of the energy,
or delta of k.
And I must put an
extra minus sign,
because these two
have opposite signs,
so I should put a minus
0 to infinity dk f of k.
And we'll have the e to the
minus i, e of k, e over h bar.
And just for reference, f of
k is some real function that
picks at some value k naught.
So you see, just
like what we did
in the case of the step
potential, in which we
had an incident wave,
a reflected wave
packet, a transmitted wave
packet, the wave packets go
along with the basic solution.
The basic solution had
coefficients A, B, and C,
and you knew what B was
in terms of A and C.
Therefore, you constructed the
incoming wave with A e to ikx,
and then the reflected wave
with B e to the minus ikx.
The same thing we're doing
here inspired by this solution,
the psi affects we
superpose many of those,
and that's what we've done here.
Now of course, we can do the
stationary phase calculations
that we've done several
times to figure out
how the peak of the
wave packet moves.
So a stationary phase
at k equal k naught.
As you remember, the
only contribution
can really come when k is near
k naught, and at that point,
you want the phase to be
stationary as a function of k.
I will not do here
the computation again
for psi incident.
You've done this computation
a few times already.
For psi incident, you find
the relation between x and t,
and I will just write it.
It's simple.
You find that x is
equal to minus h
bar k naught over mt, or
minus some v velocity, group
velocity, times t.
That is the condition
for a peak to exist.
The peak satisfies
that equation,
and this makes sense
when t is negative.
This solution for psi incident
only makes sense for x positive
if in fact x greater than R. So
this solution needs x positive.
So it needs t
negative [? indeed. ?]
This is a wave that is
coming from plus infinity,
x equal plus infinity,
at time minus infinity,
and it's going in
with this velocity.
For psi reflected,
the derivative
now has to take the derivative
of delta, with respect to e,
and then the derivative of e
with respect to the energy.
And the answer, in this case--
you've done this before--
it's v group times t minus
2 h bar delta prime of E.
So yes, in the reflected
wave, x grows as t grows
and it's positive.
t must now be
positive, but in fact,
if you would have a
just x equal v group t,
this would correspond
to a particle that
seems to start at the origin
at time equals 0 and goes out.
But this actually there is
an extra term subtracted.
So only for t greater
than this number
the particle begins to appear.
So this is a delay, t
minus some t naught,
the packet gets delayed
by this potential.
Now, this delay can
really get delayed.
Sometimes it might
even accelerated,
but in general, the delay
is given by this quantity
So I'll write it here.
The delay, delta t, is 2
h bar delta prime of E.
And let's write it
in a way that you
can see maybe the units better
and get a little intuition
about what this
computation gives.
For that, let's differentiate
this with respect to k,
and then k with
respect to energy.
So v delta with respect to k,
and dk with respect to energy.
This is 2 over 1 over h
bar dE with respect to k.
I do a little rearrangement
of this derivative
is one function
of one variable k
and neither is a
single relation.
So you can just invert it.
This is more dangerous when
you have partial derivatives.
This is not necessarily true but
for this ordinary derivatives
is true, and then you have
this 2 to the left here.
The h bar went all the way
down, and I have d delta dk.
And here, we recognize
that this is 2,
and this is nothing else
than the group velocity
we were talking before.
The E, the energy, is h
squared k squared over 2m.
You differentiate,
divide by h bar,
and it gives you the group
velocity hk naught over m.
Because these
derivatives all have
to be evaluated at k naught.
So this derivative is really
evaluated at k naught.
This is also
So this is the group velocity,
d delta, dk, and finally,
let me rewrite it in a
slightly different way.
I multiply by 1 over R. Why?
Because d delta dk, k has
units of 1 over length.
So if I multiply by 1 over
R, this will have no units.
So I claim that one over R d
delta dk is equal to delta t,
and you'll have 2 over vg
and R. So I did a few steps.
I moved the 2 over
vg down to the left,
and I multiplied by
1 over R, and now we
have a nice expression.
This is the delay.
Delta t is the
delay, but you now
have divided it by 2R divided
by the velocity, which
is the time it takes the
particle with the group
velocity to travel back and
forth in the finite range
potential.
So that gives you an idea.
So if you compute
the time delay,
again, it will have
units of microseconds,
and you may not know if
that's little or much.
But here, by computing
this quantity,
not exactly delta prime
of v but this quantity.
You get an [? insight,
?] because this is
the delay divided by
the free transit time.
It's kind of a nice quantity.
You're dividing your delay
and comparing it with the time
that it takes a particle,
with a velocity that
is coming in, to do the
bouncing across the finite range
potential.